[Applaudissements]
quelle classe at-il redoublé première la
première effectivement que la première
non
la lie quelle classe est il redouble et
par quelle place at-il triple attention
cela n'est trop facile je passe à la 6e'
règlement ou et il grandit
il a beau lilas dans le 93 serena est
très forte
c'est incroyable je suis le nom du lycée
à égalité qui attendrait asie allez
c'est elle c'est quoi hélène boucher
délit folie là à du lycée oui mais c'est
l'islam est la raison mais c'est sûr que
la raison attendant j'étais au lycée
hélène-boucher charlemagne turgot marie
curie avançait plus je vois mais sans
appeler à la raison hélène boucher sa
loge et est maintenant on va rentrer
dans un truc et hélène boucher qui est
pas du tout bush éditrice fois ci
c'était pas une question il faut
mentionner attention vous quelle est
celle est plus dure qu'elle et sa manie
jeu j'ai pas fini à québec à palerme et
quoi elle songe à l'est pour les
audiences bah ouais le jour des
audiences il porte un caleçon viol et
que les offert saveur
je vous assure qu'elle n'a pas l'air de
vue n'a pas les réponses mais sans
déconner elles sont bon dieu bénisse
tous sont timothée sur quelle chanson
voudrait-il rentrer à son mariage à
ouidah au dessus des yeux tout cet homme
c'est nouveau c'est là c'est chaud c'est
vincent certains médias fait chaud il
n'y a pas moins fait ça c'est choquant
non mais ça même mois la semaine
dernière j'ai dû au talent de carmilla
réseau with or without you well fait des
dossiers chez vous il ya des classeurs
elle a tous dans la tête
voilà tu passe le bac la gorge à merde
17 à tuer le bac mais c'est normal
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention quelques pseudo quelques seaux
d'eau voulait-il prendre en radio au
début de sa carrière il de faire en
référence à la croisade s'amuse cyril
gopher je me prenais pour l'américain
mais mais seriez lcd dos que même moi
j'ai oublié elle est très faible la
semaine dernière alors que faisait cyril
quand sa mère lui refuser des bonbons il
avait dans le cabinet de son père et il
tire il disait à tous les patients vous
êtes tous des connards
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai parce que mon père est on
habitait dans le cabinet de mon père et
donc il y avait et serviront partager et
donc voilà je rentrais ben c'est comme
ça j'ai pas tout vous êtes tous des
connards
alors qu'est ce qui se passait à ce
moment-là avec les passages avait des
bombes allaient passer ma les passions
ils ont ils ont déserté d'ailleurs c'est
l'attelage j'avais 20 ans j'avais 4 27
ans 4 euros
attention nous sommes à 2 minutes 15 du
compte à rebours pour le passage sur
canal pour la grosse c'est la très
grosse émission on va s'en faire une
autre quelle est sa plus grande phobie
société faciliter l es tu rêves
d'enfance quand il était petit devenir
joueur de tennis pro c'est vrai ouais
vous avez rien dit est-ce que juste pour
voir s'ils connaissent avis ne pas
répondre après un silence il est capable
quel était le nom de son premier one man
show alors mon premier one nation a
besoin d'un souffle art c'était quoi
c'est une nature cyril a donné l'ordre
aux métiers dans une poubelle
effectivement le côté c'est juste
fantastique
maîtresse qui va pas céder
jaune alors qu'elle voulait la rentrée
soit
est-ce que je peux est invité à passer
une journée avec moi mais oui vraiment
c'est vrai mais alors tu habites à lyon
ouais comment alors tu peux venir qu'on
veut ça mais c'est vrai mais j'arrête la
fac c'est quoi en fac tu fait qu'on fait
là là je vais en communication c'est en
communication et ben on passe une
journée dans les dents les bailleurs
chevaux par ses actionnaires jeudi
jeudi prochain l'ag au parc astérix
jeudi la whey nom est bon alors on se
redresse je vous l'envoie prêts déjà